[Music]
the legacy of that shield is
complicated
the world
is upside down
people need something to get behind
i need a symbol
so what's our plan
so no plan
[Music]
great
[Music]
what's going on in that cyborg brain of
yours you don't want to know
oh yeah i can see it working gear's
turning
oh they're malfunctioning they're on
fire
get your hands up
[Music]
wow
you're taking me somewhere to kill me no
i'm taking you someplace to talk
well i don't like to talk but you do
like to lie which you just
did because we both know you love to
talk
how long have you been here i don't know
it's hard to say
you know time passes differently here in
the tva what does that mean
you'll catch up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
glorious
[Music]
[Music]
brother i'm down
you'd better be ready
come on what did you expect
i tell people my sister moved out west
you're a science teacher
your husband he renovates houses
you're thinking about moving but you're
gonna wait until the interest rates go
down
that's not my story
before i was an avenger i made mistakes
[Music]
[Applause]
and a lot of enemies
it's called science taskmaster he
controls the red room
they're manipulated fully conscious but
no choices
i should have come back for you how many
others are there
than those
[Applause]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
you won't win i've always found it best
not to look into the past
okay you got a plan or should i just
stay dug and cover my plan was to drive
us away
gloria plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
and who you are
i need my choice
i'm done running
[Music]
here's what's going to happen natasha
don't slouch i'm not slouching you're
going to get the back hunch
listen to your mother oh my god all
right enough
all of you i didn't say anything that's
not fair
[Music]
so what's a single gal like you doing
rattling around this big howl
well i assure you i'm married to a man a
human one
oh i don't think that was ever in
question
we just don't know what to expect
howdy neighbors hey buddy
wanda what's up who are you
i don't know
i think something's wrong here
are
this is our home then let's fight for it
well i think we handled that well
space time time
time reality
it's more than a linear path it's a
prism
of endless possibility well that doesn't
sound ominous at all
[Applause]
i was promised an army
you have a super soldier
you sure don't seem too freaked out
about all this kid
what you doing out there all by yourself
anyway exploring
the world sounds fun but why stop at one
world
when we can show you all of them
[Music]
i am the watcher
i am your guide through these vast new
realities
follow me and dare to face the unknown
and ponder the question
what if
give me the tour
miss marble is a new kind of superhero
but at the core of all of it her story
is so universal
miss marvel is one of the newer
characters in the marvel comics
and when one comes in that grabs the
world's imagination like this the
questions are
when are we gonna bring miss marvel to
the screen when miss marvel first came
out we had such an incredible reaction
it was so incredibly popular because
everybody could see themselves in her
i never saw a young teenager of color
specifically a pakistani in the comic
book
are you kidding you promised you'd be
cool i am cool the casting process
was vast when we discovered iman
we knew that she was kamala khan it was
unanimous decision yeah i can't
comprehend this right now
and then of course we've got a really
incredible team of directors
mira menon and cermino beijinoi and all
of them
are taking the material and elevating it
so human it's about a teenager figuring
out who she is
and about relationships family and
friendship is at the heart
of the mcu canon that's what's so
exciting about the story that we're
bringing is that we're going to
introduce you to a new family that's
also going to be part of the wider mcu
[Music]
you